-The password is "caterpillar."
-Tina, we're gonna
start with you.
-Okay.
Cocoon.
-Caterpillar.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice!
-What? What do you mean,
cocoon, caterpillar?
-Well, that's -- there you go.
Take that, Newton, Lisa.
Newton, get ready, my man.
-The password is "blackberry."
-Here goes. Lisa go?
Okay, Lisa,
we're gonna start with you.
-Phone.
-Book.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought
you were gonna say "bone."
-Yeah, phone bone.
I did, too.
You read my mind.
-Texting.
-Blackberry?
-It is "blackberry."
-Oh!
-Whoa!
Wow!
Yeah.
-5 to 6.
-Whoo!
We did it, man.
-All right, here we go.
-Thanks, Higgs.
-The password is "mother."
-We'll start with you, Jimmy.
-Okay.
-They're a point ahead of you.
Can I talk to you for a second?
-Yeah.
Excuse us.
[ Laughter ]
The password's "mother."
What should I say?
[ Laughter ]
-I would do "father,"
but like "f-a-ather."
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
Father.
Mother.
-Yes!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Wow!
-That one doesn't count.
That one doesn't count.
The rules.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Ready?
We'll do this.
Ready, Feyzoli?
-Yeah.
-The password is "cocktail."
-Okay.
-They're a point ahead of you.
Just want you to know that.
-Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
-6-5.
-All right, stop.
Let me concentrate.
[ Laughter ]
Martini.
-Alcohol?
[ Laughter ]
-Cosmopolitan.
-Olive.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
-Uh...
Gin.
-Cocktail?
-Yes!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was gonna --
My next one was gonna be
"penis feather."
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
You should've -- that's what
you should've said.
-I should've opened
with "penis feather"
like I wanted to.
-Yeah.
-The password is "explosion."
-If I say "Kokomo,"
he's not gonna get it.
[ Laughter ]
-Newton, we're gonna start
with you.
Was that in the movie
"Cocktail"?
Is it "Kokomo"
-The song? Yeah.
-It was, right?
-Yep.
-It's a good song.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know "Kokomo"?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Too bad.
-I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
-Yes.
Boom.
[ Laughter ]
-Bomb?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Dynamite.
-Explosion?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that it, right?
That's the game.
-The password is "salsa."
-Jimmy,
why don't you start us off?
-"The password --"
Ready?
-Ready.
One word.
One word only.
-Yep.
-One word.
[ Laughter ]
-Just one.
-I know, I know, I know, I know.
Uh...
-Mamba.
-Uh, Charo.
-Ooh, no.
-Charo.
[ Laughing ]
-Natalie.
-Okay.
-Chips.
[ Laughter ]
His --
Remember his.
-Dip.
-Ooh!
Almost.
-[ Whistles ]
[ Laughter ]
Brooklyn is on the line.
-Guacamole.
-Salad.
-Oh!
[ Sad tuba ]
-No?
-Salad?
-Oh.
-3 points.
Natalie, your --
Your turn.
-Salad!
-One salad.
-Okay.
Yeah, uh, meringue.
-Salsa.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Should've guessed Cugat.
-You said "sal--".
We don't get any points
for "sal--"?
-No, you don't get half a point.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, Neil,
any word comes through...
-The password is "tickle."
-JJ, you're up first.
-JJ's up first.
-JJ is up first.
-[ Clears throat ]
This is tough.
-Oh, no.
Okay.
-Can I have like 20 minutes?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Laugh?
-Giggle.
-Ooh.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Can I use "salad" again?
Uh...
Can I get a different word?
[ Laughter ]
-You can't get a different word!
-Scratch.
-Ooh.
-Ooh, that's a good one.
Track.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Laugh track, scratch track.
Oh, track. Oh, no.
-Oh, wow.
-Scratch track, laugh track.
-That was awesome.
That's actually a great answer.
-Yeah.
It's wrong, but it's great.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, laugh and scratch.
-Feather.
-Tickle.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Smashed it!
Ooh!
Wow!
Laugh scratch is a tickle.
-I'm thinking laugh track,
scratch track.
-Yeah.
That doesn't mean --
-It wasn't as bad
as guacamole salad.
[ Laughter ]
Give me a break.
-Here we go.
Jimmy, Natalie, clue for you.
-The password is "grumpy."
-Natalie, you're gonna
start us off.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Dwarf.
-Grumpy.
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What?!
-Dwarf?
-That is nuts!
It's a barnburner -- 13 to zero.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, the final clue.
-How many points
is this one worth?
-This one?
This next one is gonna be worth
14 and a half.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Ready?
Neil?
-Neil, yeah.
Okay.
-JJ.
-The password is "mistletoe."
-Uh...
Leafy.
[ Laughter ]
-On the salad theme.
-He's obsessed with salad.
[ Laughter ]
-Can't talk about anything else.
I never heard anyone talk about
salad more in my life!
[ Laughter ]
It's unbelievable.
Are you sure you're not vegan?
I mean, it's...
[ Laughter ]
Leafy?
-Leafy.
-Oh, my goodness.
Uh...man.
What?
-Leafy.
No, you already said leafy.
Now I gotta go into this.
Leafy is...
If you have a leafy --
and I don't want to say salad --
I'm gonna say...
[ Laughter ]
a leafy...
-Go ahead.
You've got it.
-I do have it?
-Yeah, you.
It's right
at the tip of your tongue.
Leafy...
-Bush?
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe.
-Wait. Is that your answer?
[ Sad tuba ]
Oh.
This a family show.
-No, it was clear!
Leafy bush.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, bush. Okay.
-Like a hedge, like a hedge.
-Yeah, like a hedge.
Sure.
-All right.
Think about this. Ready?
-I'm good.
-Christmas.
-Mistletoe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
-The password is "pickle."
Now. You look bigger first.
-This is easy.
-Oh, man.
-Yeah, you can do this.
You can do it.
-Oh.
-One-word clue.
Looks like he's got this one.
-Oh, wow.
Oh, man. Um...
-Gosh, the first one out.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wow.
Terrible!
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Really hard.
Any -- Any word.
Except for the word.
-I already know it.
[ Laughter ]
-Cucumber.
-Goodness.
-He thought he knew it.
You thought he knew it.
Threw you off.
"Cucumber" is the clue.
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Cucumber.
Salad.
-That was incorrect.
Kari, it is your turn.
Cucumber,
and then he said salad.
-Okay. He said salad.
-Cucumber.
-So remember that.
And I'm gonna say...
pregnant.
[ Laughter ]
Stay with me, man.
Stay with me.
-So my clues are...
-Yes. Yes.
-A cucumber...
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-...salad,
and a pregnant person?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-You got this.
This is good.
-I thought, like, most shows
would give you
the answer before.
[ Laughter ]
-We have to keep it real.
-Real life game
-Yeah, this is a real game.
Yeah.
-So a pregnant person
that wants a cucumber.
-Yes.
-Wow.
-What pregnant person
would want a cucumber?
[ Laughter ]
Man.
I hope this thing
doesn't have a timer.
[ Laughter ]
-We're already into
tomorrow night's show.
-I'm not -- I'm not --
Cucumber, pregnant,
cucumber, pregnant.
Oh.
-You know this, man.
-Pregnant.
I mean, I see --
When I think of pregnant,
I think of stomach.
And when I think of cucumber,
I think of salad.
[ Laughter ]
Or a diet.
-It's not salad.
I can guarantee you that.
-I think of --
like, I think of, like --
Damn.
What was --
Man, I think
he had a bad clue, maybe.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know, man.
Maybe like -- I don't know.
Is it a diet?
Yeah, go to -- a diet.
I don't know.
It's like I'm not sure --
I'm not sure what it could be.
[ Laughter ]
-Diet?
Okay. Okay.
So, the clues so far --
cucumber and pregnant.
-Vegan.
[ Laughter ]
-No. No, no, stop!
Hey, no, stop!
You have a chance
to give another clue now.
Then, don't --
And then you say your guess.
-Vegan -- let's do it!
-It's not vegan.
-She the one that said pregnant.
Ain't nobody --
-Vinegar.
-Oh, yeah.
-Pickle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nice, nice.
Wow!
-It wasn't -- It wasn't you.
It was my partner
with the bad clue.
-Yeah, but still -- yeah.
-I mean, you know.
-Pickle was good.
All right.
Now we got 2 Chainz, Gucci.
You guys go.
-The password is "tequila."
-You're up first.
You're up first.
-Oh.
-Okay.
-Is it good?
[ Laughter ]
-Should be very easy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Patrón.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was a good clue.
-I just hope I get it right
'cause I'm so bad at this.
'Cause I'm a lightweight.
-No, whatever comes to your mind
when I say Patrón,
that's the answer.
[ Laughter ]
Don't mess this up.
Don't mess this up,
don't mess this up.
Don't mess this up.
-Oh, my God.
-You know what this is.
Come on, man.
-Tequila?
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, you got in her head,
so you didn't get a chance
on that one.
All right, here we go.
-My clues are better.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What were you gonna say, Gucci?
-Don Julio.
-That's two words!
That's two words.
[ Laughter ]
-The password is "mosquito."
-Keri, why don't you start
this time?
-Oh.
-You'll get this one.
-Ooh.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah.
It's tough.
Okay.
-Oh, wow.
-Okay, okay, okay.
Um...
-You're in like a zone
right now.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He's not even sitting
on his stool. He's floating.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't mess this up.
I got us on track.
[ Laughter ]
Can I say a blank in this?
No, I have to say one word.
-One word, yeah.
-Bite.
-You said "bite"?
[ Laughter ]
Is that what you said?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-God.
-Bite.
-[ Laughs ]
-Just take a random guess.
-I want to say rappers,
but I'm gonna say "baby."
I think babies -- babies bite.
Like, kids.
[ Laughter ]
My kids bite, so...
-Sorry, judges,
can we accept "baby"?
[ Buzzer ]
No, "baby" is not --
-All right.
-She said "bite."
Bro, don't be cheatin', bro.
-I ain't cheatin'.
-A'ight, a'ight.
-Oh, wow.
Uh...
-We got this one.
I already see it.
[ Laughter ]
-Repellent.
-What'd you say?
-Oh!
What'd he say?
-Repellent.
Man, I know that!
[ Laughter ]
-Mosquito.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, it's a barnburner!
-Wow!
-All right. Here we go!
The final clue.
It is a very tight game.
Whoever gets this will win.
Here you go, 2 Chainz.
-The password is "purple."
-He got him to say it.
-Oh, man, this so easy.
-Gucci, you got this, man.
-It's too easy.
-Man, this is --
Who doing it? Me first?
-No, me.
-No, you gotta let me go first.
They just won.
-He hasn't gone yet.
-You got this.
-Okay.
-Bro, I just --
-He didn't go yet.
[ Laughter ]
-It's too easy, man.
-Prince.
-Oh.
-I was gonna say
the same thing, man.
-Prince.
-What'd he say?
Prince. Think of Prince.
The Great Prince.
-Yeah.
-The late, great Prince.
-Could be
so many amazing things.
-There's only one Prince.
-There is.
-You know what I'm saying?
-He was the greatest.
Think the artist,
the great Prince.
-It's our turn, it's our turn.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he has --
-Prince.
-Purple.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That was purple!